c'est vrai que les gens des femmes c'est
les premières choses que je regarde
c'est les jambes
parce qu'il y a il y a beaucoup de
choses là dans le mouvement des jambes
frottement des jambes comment elles
croisent et des croise leurs jambes
comment elles ça c'est formidable ça
est-ce que vous vous avez eu beaucoup
d'aventures oui j'ai beaucoup
d'aventures
c'est ce que vous recherchez en fait je
comprends rien je veux dire j'ai eu des
aventures formidables mais je comprends
toujours rien je me gourde sans arrêt il
y a des fois je vois je vois une femme
je dis celle-là ça doit être formidable
elle va elle va être formidable et c'est
pas du tout je prends une claque chaque
fois je me goure tout le temps je
supporte pas l'échec auprès d'une femme
je ne supporte pas les chèques en
général je ne comprends pas je comprends
pas possible pourtant j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait j'ai pourtant
utilisé toutes les armes que je pouvais
utiliser et ça ne passe pas c'est
impossible je comprends pas et je suis
très étonné est-ce que vous vous plaisez
ouais je me plait bien je me plaît bien
je me trouve sympa
alors c'est vrai je me plaît bien le
matin quand je me réveille j'ai en face
de moi dans le miroir un mec sympathique
qui se marre sérieux je suis tombé
amoureux d'une Italienne
que j'ai embrassais frénétiquement tout
le temps sur la bouche j'arrêtais pas de
l'embrasser sur la bouche sans arrêt
sans arrêt et je viens de me demander de
passer la nuit avec elle mais dormir à
côté d'elle et on a passé une nuit
ensemble c'était extraordinaire
j'avais 14 ans on peut faire l'amour
mais je vous dis j'ai fait l'amour la
première fois 16 ans et demi 16 ans oui
c'est ça et on était tous été dans une
grande maison en Italie avec plein
d'enfants partout vous savez et en étant
en vacances et il y avait des Italiens
des Italiens des copains des copines
qu'on avait là et on dormait on était
cinq six dans une grande chambre comme
ça et je me souviens j'avais sauté de
mon lit dans son lit à cette fille je
m'étais blotti contre elle et on a passé
à nuit serré l'un contre l'autre à
s'embrasser sur la bouche comment vous
l'avez rencontré votre femme comment
êtes-vous et comment vous l'avez séduit
au tennis je joue au tennis contre
plus moi je perdais plus j'étais des
conflits cramoisi j'étais vidée crevée
plus et dans les tribunes il y avait
cette fille qui allait devenir ma femme
et qui était mort de rire ce que je
trouvais assez séduisant c'est qu'elle
s'amuse de ça mais en même temps je ne
supportais pas qu'elle reste sur cette
image et je crois que ce qui s'est
installé entre elle et moi c'est
l'humour le rire des complicités
furtives comme ça des tas de regards
très rapides qui en disent beaucoup et
et je crois beaucoup au regard je crois
beaucoup plus qu'aux mot quelquefois au
geste
au déplacement dans l'espace des gens
comment ils bougent et elle bougeait
très bien et ça c'est très important une
femme qui bouge très bien elle savait
bouger elle disparaissait comme ça blof
là elle revenait clac c'était bien et
chaque fois qu'elle apparaissait quelque
part d'ailleurs encore maintenant il se
passe quelque chose dans l'espace
j'éprouve du plaisir
à voir ma femme désirée par quelqu'un au
sens tout à fait correct du terme
quand elle marche dans la rue et que les
gens se retournent sur elle les hommes
se retournent sur elle ou même les
femmes je veux dire je trouve ça
flatteur pour moi je suis très fier
d'avoir à mes bras quelqu'un qui est
désiré inconsciemment bon etc
et ça excite ce sentiment de de
propriété que j'ai c'est presque un peu
perversité c'est maintenant si on va
beaucoup plus loin dans ce genre de
choses la perversité c'est quelque chose
qui est presque indispensable dans les
rapports entre hommes et femmes
attention je parle pas attention moi
c'est moi ça se situe pas au niveau
fouette moi accroché un radiateur ça n'a
rien à voir c'est plutôt intellectuel
au niveau des fantasmes qui ont une
légère
un léger strabisme par exemple
ça me plaît bien de pas les filles qui
louches mais un léger strabisme ça a
quelque chose d'assez excitant je sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas pourquoi mais
je ne sais pas c'est un côté
c'est complètement original je sais pas
si c'est un côté coquin dans le regard
d'une fille qui est une légère légère
légère léger strabisme attention je
m'entends bien c'est pas louché
carrément c'est un strabisme léger bon
je vous passe les les fantasmes d'amour
dans les ascenseurs dans les cuisines
les parties de jambes en l'air en plein
de neige tas de choses j'aime bien ça je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai envie de faire
l'amour à ma femme quand elle fait en
train de faire cuire deux œufs je sais
pas pourquoi c'est pas pourquoi
et ça ça vous arrive souvent
elle est en train de bricoler dans la
cuisine ça ça me plaît bien
moi je suis fidèle oui oui oui
absolument
c'est le problème c'est de savoir si on
est bien dans sa tête si on est fidèle
dans sa tête si on est heureux avec
celle qu'on aime et si on est bien dans
sa tête la fidélité c'est dans la tête
en fait je crois
on a des métiers qui vous mettent en
contact avec beaucoup de gens et en
particulier avec beaucoup de femmes si
on a les aventures extra-conjugales
chose qui peut arriver ma femme le sait
ça ne changera rien tant que j'ai avec
elle un rapport d'amour et amoureux
profond et que c'est dans ma tête que
les choses sont les mêmes si ça change
dans ma tête à ce moment-là elle peut
commencer à s’angoisser et moi je peux
mettre en doute mes relations avec à ce
moment-là mais si j'ai vraiment pour
elle de l'amour et que dans ma tête je
suis hyper rien de change je crois que
elle à l'intelligence de ça et moi j'ai
moi ça m'arrange
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]